narrated and the emotions are just gonna
get wild
so my prediction will be one one and
we'll perhaps
see an armageddon yeah wow magnus
carlton
starts the blitz he makes wesley so
smile he's played the orangutan
opening again third time in this
tournament magnus he's an animal he's
channeling his orangutang how
remind me what did those games end up
with
because that was against nakamura right
yeah first time against giri he was
better and it was a draw second game
against nakamura he was worse but it was
also a draw
okay so magnus often this move is for
surprise value
um but it's unlikely to come as a
surprise this is the third time he's
played at this tournament wesley
immediately reacting pushing a pawn in
the center
white's bishop coming out to its longest
diagonal wesley he
when surprised tends to just revert to
simple solid play just going to develop
white pushing a pawn there but this must
be something that
wesley would have considered and come up
with an idea against